як може таке трапитися вперше в
українській історії українського
парламентаризму коли зала проголосувала
поправку яка не дає на так званий
марафон 2 млрд грн і від уряду нам
повертається знову таки бюджет Сема
двома мільярдами гривень на олігархічні
телеканали власники яких є монополістами
в інших сферах і точно можуть
фінансувати свої телезабаганки сьогодні
коли наші виборці
різного віку збирають по Копійці на
Дрони на байрактари на шелди на
броньовані машини Ми з бюджету будемо
фінансувати марафон кожна копійка яка
відірвана сьогодні від армії це знаєте
це є корупція і тому наша вимога щоби
була поставлена ще раз на підтвердження
ця поправка щоби 2 млрд грн пішли на
армію А якщо дуже хочеться фінансувати
марафон нехай збирають там донати всі
хто хочеться дивитися на це збирають
гроші